Linden schaffer is a wellness travel expert and consultant early on in her
fashion career should realize the way she worked was turning her into a tightly
wound ball of stress intention,
which I'm sure many of us can relate to.
So before every business trip she conducted hours of research,
planning her own self care in her few precious hours of downtime and it changed
your life.
Today Linden leads travelers around the world on wellness vacations of via
provosts provoca the first wellness travel company.
Lyndon has been recognized as a leader in her field and as a winner of the
prestigious British Airways faced of opportunity contest.
She contributes to columns in the Huffington post and mindbodygreen where she
writes about wellness,
travel and lifestyle.
She's a regular speaker at conferences including the New York Times and Los
Angeles Times.
Travel shows her first book living well on the road.
Health and wellness for every traveler became a number one bestseller upon
release.
And here's London.
Good afternoon.
Thank you Jillian so much for hosting me.
Thanks to Google.
Thank you guys for spending your lunch time with me.
I'm really excited to be here today and talk to you about living while on the
road or what I also call how to plan a business trip that doesn't kill you.
Very important in the day and age that we work in.
So who am I and why am I here to talk to you about this today?
I am the girl who at 16 years old had my first international travel experience
and it's something that stuck with me.
I went and was able to go to Australia and ever since then my wonder lost and my
idea of wanting to explore the world was deeply seated and rooted in me.
I spent 15 years in the fashion industry in New York City and my time there I
would go in for my job interviews and we'd have this great interview.
We talk about what I was doing or about to do with this company and at the end
the interview or I'd say,
Hey,
do you have any questions?
And I would say yes.
How much is this a work travel situation and how much vacation time do I get?
So you can imagine these interviewers were like,
wait a second,
you're your biggest concern about this job is how much time you get to spend out
of the office.
Okay,
let's think about this a little bit.
So luckily enough,
throughout the career that I had in the fashion industry,
I was able to travel a lot.
I would tremble domestically,
I would travel internationally,
I would travel for weeks on end with no break in between.
And there was one morning waking up in a hotel room in Italy and having no idea
where I was.
So I'm sure that's happened to some of you in this room before.
You have no idea between the jet lag between where you were yesterday,
where you're going tomorrow,
where are you?
And I said,
you know what?
I gotta do something here has got to give something's gotta change.
I can't be stressed out.
I can't be out.
I can't be productive in this situation.
So what is it that I can do to change the way that I'm living while I travel?
So what I did was I started to just simply pool for from tools that I had used
in my own life.
So whether it was yoga practicing or meditation or eating healthy at home,
I figured there's got a way be a way that I can implement this while I'm on the
road as well.
So I started doing my own little tips and tricks and I would take that circuit
again.
I would see the same people that I was always traveling with and they would look
at me and they would say,
you know what,
Linden?
You seem rested.
You seem happy,
you seem healthy.
What has changed and how do I get that?
So I started to think to myself,
okay,
there must be something here.
Everybody is stressed out,
burnt out,
living on the road when they travel for business and they need to get some
sanity back.
They need to get some semblance of themselves back.
And this led organically to the launch of [inaudible],
which is the wellness travel company I run.
It was the first wellness travel company that was created here in the US.
And throughout that time,
the clients that I would take on the road for these health and wellness
vacations and wanted more information,
uh,
how do I implement this when I get home?
Traveling with you is fantastic,
but now I need to figure out how to put this into my own lifestyle,
which is,
uh,
how living well on the road came to be.
It's the book you guys are all getting a copy of today.
Uh,
that goes into health and wellness,
the science behind it.
Why these things work,
which is what we're going to talk through a little bit today.
So one of the things I think we can all agree on is that travel is stressful.
There's no way around that.
And the first thing that we have to do is sort of recognize that and say to
ourselves,
why,
why is trouble stressful?
Because as humans,
we are hardwired to avoid negative experiences.
We've all had a bad travel experience,
we've missed a flight,
we've run for a flight,
we've had an altercation maybe with the gate agent who wouldn't get us on that
flight.
Whatever it is,
right?
So those are the experiences we internalize and they experiences that we
remember.
And so we start to make our decisions from this fear based place of I don't want
to do that.
I don't want to do that.
So let's talk a little bit about that fear base and how and what it is that it
that it does to us.
And then let's learn some tools with,
of how to deal with that and move on.
So we're,
when we're talking about the stress of travel,
it,
the stress of travel affects our whole mind,
body connection,
the physical,
the mental,
and the emotional.
When it comes to our physical selves.
You can picture yourself now,
right?
You're running through the airport and you're trying to make that flight.
You're the last person on the plane.
There's no room for your luggage.
So you're trying to cram it in.
You're trying to cram yourself into the seat,
right?
All of these things are completely stressful and take our body out of whack.
We're disrupting her sleep patterns.
When we change time zones,
even,
especially if we're doing it for a short period of time,
uh,
we're increasing our sedentary behavior.
Uh,
you know,
you guys here at Google are lucky enough to have these great outdoor spaces in
these conference rooms so you can get up and move around a little bit.
That's not the typical workplace environment these days.
So people are taking themselves from sitting behind a desk to sitting on a plane
for hours on end,
right?
This is stressing our physical system when it comes to our mental system.
We're also taxing our brains.
We live in this day and age because we're so connected all the time.
And with everything that we do,
we live in a constant state of chronic stress.
On some level,
we have moved away from being in that nice relaxed place to being in that place
where we're constantly in our fight or flight mode.
So add on top of that business travel,
right?
You have to make sure you're working very well,
but then you also have to make sure like,
oh,
how am I going to pack a,
am I prepping for my meetings properly?
And then the,
the anxiety and the worry on that to add it on top of that when it comes to all
of these things.
So our brain starts to work overtime.
In our emotional state,
we have anxiety around travel.
Um,
there is a lot going on in the world today,
whether it's where we're traveling,
whether it's going through the airport itself,
we start to get anxious.
Um,
am I going to make that flight?
Have I prepped for that meeting really well?
Am I going to have an issue when I land on the ground?
Uh,
there's also a lot of mistrust these days in the travel industry.
I'm sure we've all seen the viral videos that have come out and done the last
few weeks even specifically,
right?
So the clients,
uh,
and,
and everyone who is traveling has an inherent mistrust of these companies that
we are in trusting our business travel to.
And then fear.
So back to this,
making decisions from a place of fear.
Some people are afraid of flying.
So that itself,
you know,
sets you up in a negative space before you've even taken off.
So these are all things that we have to deal with when it comes to trouble.
So why do we do it?
Right?
Why do companies keep sending us out?
What is the benefit of business travel?
Uh,
and there there are many benefits to business travel.
The biggest things here are it builds relationships and retention.
And that is not only from the client and employer side,
but also from the employee to the employer side.
So when you're able to get on the road and you meet your clients face to face,
it builds these relationships.
It builds these relationships between you and your client and you bond with your
client when you're in front of them.
Um,
and,
and it endears you a bit to them.
You build this personal relationship.
Also on the other spectrum of that,
employees who like to travel or who,
who travel a lot and have found ways through these tips that we're going to walk
through to make,
uh,
make it a little bit of a leisure and enjoyable experience at the same time,
you will stick with your company longer.
So that's great for the company as well.
It increases productivity when you have face to face meetings and you're able to
sit in front of somebody and talk through problems,
talk through solutions,
it increases the project.
I'm sure all of you.
Uh,
maybe today,
maybe tomorrow we'll be on a conference call,
right?
So we thought,
oh,
when conferencing gets big,
when video conferencing gets big,
we're not going to need that face to face meeting anymore.
And actually that hasn't proved to be true.
We are more productive when we have our PR person to person face to face
meetings.
So when you're on a conference call,
I'm sure many of you have done it,
the statistics are that 60% of people on a conference call are also doing
something else at the same time.
So they're not really paying attention to what's going on.
And some of that's because maybe you're on this big call with all these people
and you're not needed at that moment.
So you're checking your email,
you're figuring out what your dinner plans are going to be,
you know,
whatever it is.
Um,
uh,
and,
and other statistics that have come out around the conference call,
right?
Um,
and I will tell you right now,
I've never been one of these people that over 50% have admitted that while on a
conference call,
they've been in the bathroom.
So I'm hoping that they were on mute,
right?
Nobody wants to hear that.
But these are the things that when you have face to face meetings,
you,
they don't happen.
You don't get distracted.
Um,
getting up,
getting,
moving,
getting out of your typical environment.
Um,
whether it's a cubicle or an office promotes out of the box thinking and
creativity.
It puts you in real life situations where you're taught to think on your feet
and you're taught to be flexible.
So these are all things that companies in,
in terms of why they want you to business travel makes it productive and
beneficial for them as well as for yourself.
Uh,
the statistics around the spending for business travel are huge.
The global business travel spend in 2015 was one point $2 trillion and it's
rising every year.
It's also something that actually rises during a recession.
And because companies have found that back to these first three things that we
talked about,
uh,
relationships in retention,
productivity and creativity are things that keep clients around longer.
So even in a downturn,
people are spending on business travel.
And why is this?
Because of what is invested,
the return is very high.
So every dollar that's invested that a company invests in sending you on the
road,
they see an increase in of $9 and 50 cents in their revenue and $2 and 90 cents
in profit.
So that's why you're getting sent on the road all the time.
So how has travel changing business travel has completely shifted,
uh,
in the last 10 years,
32% of millennials who are doing business travel.
And have some control over their schedule themselves are booking directly on
their phone.
They're researching and booking on their phone,
which has created this great world,
uh,
for all the apps and all the ways that are becoming coming out now that support
business travel,
non traditional booking platforms are becoming more acceptable in traditional
companies.
So the shared economy of things like Airbnb,
lift,
Uber,
they're,
they're um,
creating business divisions that are,
that are partnering with corporations and allowing you to stay like this.
What's really interesting in terms of accommodations and in terms of blurring
this line between business and leisure,
uh,
four 56% of people who book a on an Airbnb type platform for your accommodations
on average book,
five night trips.
Whereas when you're solely looking at hotels,
you're booking three night trips.
So you can see when it comes to this idea of figuring out how business travel is
working for you,
this is something interesting that comes into play as far as that's concerned.
Everything is ending up on social media.
This is a huge change that's really exploded in the last two or three years.
And you can find the stuff on any platform.
It's not specific to one or the other.
So here's the thing about business travel and people posting about it on social
media.
They post the good,
they post the bad,
which we all know,
but companies are also interacting with their clients when it comes to social
media and it's really become an acceptable way to get real time feedback.
So I can give you an example.
A few years ago my husband and I were in Colombia and I was there on business
and we came at different times.
And so we had separate flights out.
He was booked on a jet blue flight and,
and there was only one flight a day and a three flights a week that we're
departing,
uh,
where we were in Columbia and he missed his flight for whatever reason,
right?
So there was nothing he could do.
He couldn't get on another flight with jet blue.
He had to figure stuff out himself.
But what he did immediately was he tweeted JetBlue about his problem and they
responded right away apologizing and giving him a travel credit for everything
that he went through.
So this goes back to how is the industry changing both the way that we use it
and the way that the companies are interacting with their clients.
The biggest change in the last few years when it comes to business travel deals
with perception and this perception is both how the employer views business
travel and the employee as well.
So businesses see people who are willing to travel for business as more valuable
employees.
And that goes back to that productivity creativity idea that we were talking
about.
Um,
it sparks new ideas.
It sparks partnerships,
it sparks more loyalty when you're working face to face with other people.
And it's really interesting this day and age when it comes to travel.
Uh,
30% of people who are interviewing for new jobs have said that they are willing
to take a pay cut or a lateral move if it means they're able to travel for
business more.
So think about that,
right?
It is becoming more acceptable to be out of the office.
It's becoming more acceptable to work in different ways.
And employers are recognizing these benefits and figuring out how they can tie
that back to their companies being more profitable.
So
now that you know that it's time to travel,
right?
We know what the benefits are for the companies and we know what the detriments
are to ourselves.
How do we change those detriments into positives for ourselves when we travel?
How do we counteract those physical,
mental,
and emotional tolls that are created and so that we can function option optimal,
Molly,
when we're traveling.
So what you need to do is you need to create some tools for yourself.
So what I want you to do here today,
little experiment to see how it works for you.
Uh,
we're going to do a breathing exercise.
So I want you to take anything that's on your lap and shifted off.
I want you to scoot forward in your chair so that you can feel your feet on the
ground.
Okay?
I want you to sit up straight.
Rest your hands in your lap so you feel comfortable.
Okay.
And then I want you to trust me and I want you to close your eyes.
So take a second here just to check in with yourself,
to take a pause.
And I want you to breathe in.
Take a deep breath in,
and I want you to release it out your mouth.
So breathe in and release your breath.
Breathe in through your nose and release it out through your mouth.
So now that you're centered and you're feeling yourself in the room right now,
I want you to repeat in your mind on your inbreath the words I am and on your
outbreath here.
Okay.
So breathe in.
I am.
Okay.
Breathe out here.
Breathe in.
I am
breathe out here.
So do it a few more times on your own
and now open your eyes.
So hopefully that few seconds of breathing that I just taught you is the first
tool that you can sort of put in your business travel toolbox.
So what just happened?
We removed some of your external stimulation by closing your eyes.
And by being in this room where it's quiet,
we took away the visual and the audio sensory loads that we all have these days
where we're technically overloaded on all that.
Being able to take away outside input and outside sense sensory,
uh,
it allows us to shift our subconscious thinking.
It brings us into the here and now by focusing your mind on your breath,
by focusing your mind on that I am here statement,
you're bringing yourself into the present moment.
You're not thinking about something that just happened.
You're not thinking about what's coming up this afternoon.
You're,
you're making yourself present and all of this helps trigger a relaxation
response.
So the idea by removing the sensory input by,
by going inside,
even if it's just for a breath or two and focusing on yourself,
you're,
you're restricting the flow of cortisol,
which is our stress hormone and it's constantly producing.
So if we can find a way to reshift not only our thinking,
but Reese reshaped the way the chemistry is in our brain and we're,
we're taking ourselves out of that survival mode,
out of that fight or flight mode.
And into the present,
we can learn to relax.
So some people may have felt anxiety or discomfort while we did that,
which is totally fine.
This is how I felt the first way I,
the first time I did it to my couldn't focus.
My mind was everywhere.
This was something that was totally new and different to me and I was like,
how am I supposed to relax when I'm doing this?
Right?
It takes practice and that's,
that is just,
you have to put something into it to get something great out of it.
And the reason this is is because what we just did affects the prefrontal cortex
of our brain.
We have all these neuro transmitters in there and they start firing on high
speed when we're doing something new and different and uncomfortable and
immediately our brains has to us warning danger.
Don't do that.
Don't go there.
So it takes some time for us to retrain ourselves.
It takes some time for us to stabilize these neurotransmitters in our brain and
create these new pathways that will lead us to relaxation.
So what's great about that exercise,
that first tool that you now have in your toolbox,
you can do it anywhere.
You can do it.
When you're stuck in traffic,
you can do it.
When you're in an Uber on the way to the airport,
you can do it when you're sitting at the airport and your flight was delayed and
there's nothing you can do about it.
You can do it when you get on the airplane,
right?
So this is the first thing that you can do to set yourself up,
to have a positive experience,
to set yourself up,
to change the narrative and change the story that you tell yourself that
business travel is stressful.
So let's flip it around.
Let's,
let's reorder the way that our brain is firing and let's say to ourselves,
we can start this from are relaxed and positive place.
So let's get to some practicalities here.
What are you packing when it comes time for your business trip?
I have some props in the back of the room that you can take a look at on your
way out.
Um,
I prepack I have an,
uh,
a section of stuff in my house,
in a drawer in my closet that has all the things that I know throughout
developing my travel routine that are prepacked and I,
it's one less thing I have to stress and worry about when it comes time to get
ready for a business trip.
For me,
I focus on five areas that are going to affect my health and wellness when I
travel,
how I sleep,
how I eat,
how I move,
how to stay healthy,
and how am I going to work.
And so there's easy things that don't take up a lot of room that you can keep
prepacked even in your suitcase if you want.
So then you don't even have to remember what drawer you put it in,
right?
We want to take all these choices in all these decisions away and make it easy
for ourselves.
We want to set ourselves up.
We want to take out that stress and make it to make it into success.
So traveling with things like earplugs or I'm asks for the plane,
I'm Aipac,
nutrient rich snacks.
Um,
I have,
whether it's Allman butter or something like this that is going to keep me
healthy and happy.
And that way if I get somewhere we were,
we were just talking before I came up on stage about how you land somewhere and
it's too late to have dinner and you end up reaching for crop while when you
have stuff packed with you that you know is healthy and good for you,
then great there,
there is no decision there.
You've cut all of that out when it comes to movement.
If you can pack workout clothes,
if that's too much for you,
take a jump rope,
take one of those therabands that you've seen.
Uh,
you can use props that don't take up a lot of room to keep yourself moving.
And even if it's for 10 minutes,
right,
you can move on to get up and move on the plane,
uh,
or you can use these props when you get to your hotel room.
Uh,
staying healthy is a big one.
when we're changing all these environments,
we're meeting all these new people were shaking hands,
things like that.
Aside from washing your hands,
what can you do to stay healthy when you travel?
Um,
drink a lot of water,
more,
more water than you would normally drink.
I would say reach for that as the first thing.
Things like coffee and alcohol dehydrate you.
So if you're going to,
um,
be heavy on the coffee and the alcohol,
think about that and purposely drink more water to counteract those effects as
well.
Um,
I travel with these amazing,
uh,
wipes that are these essential oil wipes.
They smell like lavender,
which is great because they smell good and lavender is relaxing.
Uh,
and it's also an anti,
it has antibacterial properties.
So the first thing I do when I get onto a plane,
or the first thing I do when I get into a hotel room is I break open those wipes
and I wiped everything down,
um,
to make sure that I am cleaning it for whatever was there before me.
Right?
I,
there is a woman that I fell on the plane,
uh,
coming here out to La Actually,
who had this awesome,
I hadn't seen it before.
It was sort of like a fitted bed sheet that was made for her plane seat.
So she pulled that whole thing out and just covered it,
covered it up.
So there's things that are coming out into the marketplace that make it easy for
you.
So you keep these things packed when it comes to work.
Um,
chargers,
adapters,
USB cords,
business cards.
These are things that we probably have two or three of.
Right.
So,
so take a pile of that and put it in in your suitcase,
put it in your pre travel pack and you take out that stress as far as that's
concerned.
What about your pre travel routine?
So this is something that's going to take you a little while to cultivate and
develop because it is going to be specific to what you like and how you live.
Um,
it,
it took me a long time to cultivate my routine.
It's a 24 hour routine of self care.
Uh,
and I extended,
I extended to 48 hours if I'm going away for a long time or if I'm going really
far.
Um,
and for me,
this is what has set me up for success.
This by,
by sticking to this routine,
if you ha you land and you have meetings or if you land and you will immediately
have to go to be a business dinner,
our conference or whatever it is,
you already know that you're starting off from a place of health and wellness.
So what this means for me,
oftentimes I'll take red eye flights.
Uh,
so my 24 hour self care routine starts by the way that I sleep the night before
I leave.
So for me,
that seven to eight hours of quality sleep and the first thing that I do when I
wake up the next morning,
his workout and that workout can be anything that is good for you.
Anything that you like to do.
Um,
I try all these different crazy workout routines,
uh,
to experiment and see what I like.
Uh,
this is one of my favorites.
Doing some aerial work here.
Uh,
hanging upside down gets all of your,
your lymphatic system moving,
your Oregon's moving.
So it doesn't have to be a traditional workout routine.
Get,
get yourself moving because you know,
you're setting yourself up to be on a plane for a little while.
Uh,
you can move through this whole routine,
uh,
and use this as a guideline for yourself.
I drink my veggies,
I want to make sure I'm getting all the vitamins and minerals and nutrients that
I need and I'm not sure where we're at,
what I'm going to eat when I land.
So I sort of pregame it that way,
right?
Making sure I get all the things that I need.
I moved throughout the day,
so I'll have walking meetings.
If I'm meeting people somewhere,
um,
I will get up and I will walk and get lunch instead of eating it at my desk,
I will consume extra water.
I always have a portable water bottle with me wherever I go.
Ah,
you can fill it up in the airport as well before you even get on the plane,
which is great.
I have what I call a nutrient rich last meal,
so I don't eat on the plane.
I fast on the plane and I'm going to talk about that in a second.
So in order to set myself up to do that,
I need to make sure that that lasts two meal that I'm eating before I fly for 16
hours,
let's say to Asia,
uh,
is something like salmon and Keenwah or Pharaoh,
at,
with spinach.
So I want to make sure I'm getting these healthy fats.
I want to make sure that I'm getting something with protein.
Again,
something that's nutrient rich that will keep me full and keep me healthy,
uh,
before I get on the plane.
So I'm not tempted to reach for um,
uh,
you know,
m and m's or something like this.
Um,
I pack snacks,
which we talked about,
which are great for if you get hungry on the plane or when you land,
if it's something that you need.
And then I also plan my plane time.
A lot of people you'll,
you'll say like,
oh,
I hate flying because it's the,
this dead time for me.
Right.
Flip that story in your mind,
what can you do with those hours of travel?
For me,
I love to not be online.
I know you can pay for Wifi these days,
but I'm like,
forget it.
I'm connected all the rest of my life.
The time on the plane is for me to do things my way.
So whether that for me is writing in my journal,
whether it's watching a movie,
I've been wanting to see whether it's trying to get some extra sleep,
whatever it is,
it could be work,
that's fine,
but plan,
play in your time so you can use it effectively and again about,
it's all about setting yourself up for success.
So how are you healthy on the go?
We've talked about what you need to have packed in waiting.
We talked about your pre travel routine that you need to set up for yourself.
That's gonna work for you.
So now that you're ready,
now that you're in the air and on your way,
how do you stay healthy?
So technology,
you gotta love it because people are coming up with all these amazing ways to
stay happy and healthy when you travel.
Uh,
these are three categories that I look at a lot when it comes to the,
the technology that I have on my phone's in my tablets.
So food,
hotel in wellness are big areas.
Um,
there are some great food apps out there,
a one called grab.
So if you do a lot of domestic travel,
download this to your phone.
And what it is is it gives you in major cities around the world that their
airport menu layout for all of the restaurants that are in the airport.
So you can search through,
you already know what's going to be in the terminal,
you already know where it is,
bonus,
you can preorder your food.
So this way there's no waiting in line,
there's no wasting time figuring it out.
Where,
where you want to eat,
what you want to eat.
Is it healthy?
So it's a great app that does it for you.
I'm happy cow if you've ever heard of it as a Vegan Vegetarian App,
uh,
that's actually worldwide and,
and recommends restaurants around the world.
Hotel apps day use is one of my favorites.
So there's this,
this trend that started a few years ago were hotel re hotels realize,
look,
we have these empty rooms,
right?
Uh,
even if we're 90% occupancy,
which is a great number for a hotel,
there are still a number of rooms at each hotel every day that go unused,
they have decided to target to the business traveler.
So this day use app lets you rent a hotel room for a few hours,
which is awesome because what can happen is,
let's say you're in town for a day and you arrive early,
but you don't have a meeting to late at night.
You can pay for a fan to hook a great hotel,
uh,
for a few hours using this app and you can shower,
you can have a nap.
What's even better,
you get access to the amenities of the hotel.
So the first thing I do is head to the steam room or the sauna,
right?
That is a treat.
And that is something that is gonna gonna reset and refresh you,
especially after being on an airplane.
And it's a good use of your time where you're not necessarily sitting in an
airport lounge.
So check that out.
That's a great piece of travel technology.
Um,
and of course there's well new wellness apps that come out every day.
Headspace,
if you've heard of it,
it's a meditation APP.
Headspace is actually partnered with some airlines out there,
so you can have this access to this app in plain as well on the screen in front
of you.
And train is a great sleep cycle app that was developed with the University of
Michigan and it helps you sort of retrain yourself when you're trying to get
over jet lag.
And so on the plane,
this is the big thing.
So you have all these apps,
you have these ways to set you up,
you're ready when you land,
but on the plane itself,
especially when you're on the plane for this long time,
um,
how do you optimize your health and wellness?
The first thing is really easy.
You just want to smile at everybody when you're going through the airport.
Um,
we talked about how detrimental travel can be and most of travelers out there
are operating from that space,
right?
So it takes,
it's simple smile to make somebody's Day.
It also endears you to the staff of that airplane,
right?
You're angling for that upgrade.
You're angling for,
you know,
whatever it is,
that extra blanket,
um,
smile at everybody there.
There's no harm in it.
It only sets you up,
uh,
to,
to be in a happy place.
Uh,
we talked about wiping it down,
the wipes or the seat cover that will keep you healthy.
This is the big one.
Skipping the food and beverage that's offered on the plane.
Um,
and I know some people like,
okay,
the food and business class and first class is the best.
Why would I skip that?
I have to tell you that both Gordon Ramsay and Anthony Bordain have swear that
they will never,
ever,
ever eat airplane food.
So that should tell you something and they understand the food process,
number one.
Uh,
so they know what that whole backend looks like and they won't touch it.
Um,
in general,
what happens scientifically when we travel the airplane pressure in the cabin
plays with our taste buds and with our texture.
And so to counteract that,
the airlines have had to develop food products that tastes good.
So how do they do that?
They pick high calorie,
high fat,
high sugar items that will counteract the,
the,
um,
dampening of our,
of our tastes and our texture.
So the bottom line is whatever kind of food that they're feeding you,
it,
it's not healthy.
So it's healthier to not eat or it's healthier to bring your own snacks on the
plane.
Uh,
when it comes to beverages,
we talked about alcohol and coffee and how they dehydrate you.
You're atmosphere in that plane,
in that air cabin pressure dehydrates you.
So you're just adding to the mix.
You're compounding that dehydration when you drink alcohol and coffee on the
plane.
Um,
the other thing that I should warn you about is they don't wash those coffee
pots very often.
So think about that the next time that you want to have coffee on the plane and
maybe that will deter you and you'd rather wait til you land and you pick it up
with your grab app instead.
So it's waiting there for you.
Um,
and then returned to that breath exercise.
We just did return to that.
I am here.
You can,
you can,
uh,
just breathe if you want.
Uh,
but use this as a time to,
to kind of tune out everything around,
around you and tune into yourself.
The number one travel hack that I can recommend if you don't have it already as
global entry.
Um,
have you as everybody here have global entry?
Yes.
No.
Yeah.
Okay.
You want to get it?
It's $100.
The best hundred dollars I've ever spent.
Um,
and what it does is it gives you TSA precheck so you don't have to wait in line
when you get to the airport.
You don't have to take your shoes off,
you don't have to take your laptop out.
You get through the line really quickly.
And now on the backend from international travel,
when you come home,
you,
I have timed my entry into the country from the moment I step off the plane to
the moment that I am at the curb outside has,
is eight minutes on average.
Granted,
I only take a carry on,
right?
But eight minutes,
I have just skipped a whole lot of stress.
So whether I'm coming back from business and I want to go home and get some
sleep or whether I'm coming back from vacation,
you hold on to that,
that more zen vibe,
right?
When you're not immediately assaulted with these things.
So global entry,
highly recommend it if you,
if you don't have it already.
So all of these things that we've been talking about,
all of these tools are we're using to increase our success.
We're taking those detriments we talked about in the beginning,
those,
those lugging around,
um,
suitcases,
those worrying about your flight,
worrying about what you packed,
worrying if jet lag is going to affect you.
And we're finding new ways to,
to allow ourselves to optimally function,
um,
to enjoy this travel experience a little bit more by putting a little effort
into it at the time.
You'll find more tips on this in the book.
Um,
but you have to really dive into and find out for yourself sort of what the
pressure points are and what makes you not enjoy travel or what makes it hard to
travel and change that narrative.
Change the way that you think about those things that you do for yourself.
So now you're ready to rock your trip,
right?
And you're all set up.
You have a great pre travel routine,
you figured out how to stay healthy on the plane.
So how do you make the most of your trip?
Because you know when you leave,
some of your time is going to be spent on work.
Some of it will be personal time,
especially again,
we're extending our stays to add personal time into our vacations in some way.
So how do you take advantage of all your surroundings when you're doing this?
When it comes to work?
These are the three main things that eat up our time when we're business
traveling.
We're in these face to face meetings,
which we talked about because of that retention.
Um,
and creativity that it sparks.
We're dealing with our email and we're in events.
So whether that's conferences,
whether that's team dinners,
whatever it is.
So how do we change how we approach these meetings so that it works for
everybody.
One idea is just to get out of the office setting if you can.
So I don't know if you've heard of this,
but there's this phenomenon that's been sweeping some companies,
um,
called sweat sessions.
Has anyone ever had a sweat session with their client?
And you even know what that is?
It's taking your meeting out of the office and taking it into a healthy
environment.
So meet your client.
Are you are,
you know,
have you had this relationship with your client for a while?
You know,
they love PyLadies,
you know,
they love spin class.
You know,
they love to,
uh,
you know,
they have a favorite healthy breakfast spot.
Change your meeting there,
change your meeting to a different environment and you'll have,
you'll notice how again,
it will bond you to your client a little more.
You have more to talk about,
um,
outside of the office.
Uh,
and it sparks that creative thinking as well when it comes to email,
if you have the opportunity where you are when you travel more of a digital
nomad,
set yourself up for the opportunity to focus on email at segmented times.
So you know what I can do,
especially here in La,
right?
We don't have the beach in New York.
That's where I want to be.
So I will set aside an hour,
let's say in the morning or in the afternoon,
I will go to the beach.
I will,
um,
take whatever device I need and that will be my email time and I can get
everything banged out in that hour in an awesome environment.
I see something more than the four walls of my hotel room,
which can really be a drag.
And it,
it grounds me to the space of where I am and it changes.
It makes me happier.
It makes me happier to get out of the indoors.
We spend 80% of our time inside.
So if we can do a few things to shift that and get us outdoors more or get us
into a different environment,
more than go for it when it comes to events and entertaining.
Um,
see if there's a way that you can sort of control some of this.
I can tell you that in the last few years of my job in the fashion industry,
I would probably spend five times a year in Vegas.
And when we were there,
the,
we were required to entertain clients every night.
So we'd have this full day of working full day of standing up on my feet.
And then I was expected to entertain that night,
which is totally fine.
But what I said to my boss at one point is like,
look,
if I'm required to do this,
then I want a planet.
I want to be in charge of how this goes down.
Right?
So luckily there's great options in Vegas and in most places in the world,
if you do a little bit of research,
I was able to find restaurants that had healthier foods.
I was able to find restaurants that really cared about their ingredient and it
offered me something as well as offered the client something so you can have
that control over it.
If you're in a conference,
talk to the conference planner and say,
you know what?
I know you usually serve lunch meats,
but maybe we can get something different this time.
Maybe we can get something healthy this time.
Um,
you are very lucky that the company that you work at right now,
uh,
has been a leader in this and really cares about the employees and the,
and their health.
And so they go out of their way to provide some of these options.
But that's not always the case.
So we're working and we're on when we're business traveling,
but we also have personal time.
We also have downtime.
So that's something that is really important for you to remember.
Just because you're on a business trip.
Does it mean that company Ozu 24 seven you have to find a way to just like you
would at home disconnect and do something for yourself every day.
So it's up to you figure out why,
where you can control your areas of your business trip.
Is it your schedule?
Are you able to push meetings later in the day?
Is that when you work best?
Is that give you time to use one of these hotel rooms for a few hours in
refresh?
Are you able to control your food or your fitness or your sleep or how you
recover or are you able to plan on both ends to extend your trip so you make it
more interesting for yourself?
You make it more of a discovery option
and then your environment,
right?
We talked about seeing the four walls of your hotel room have to tell you,
I have a pretty good job.
This is what my environment tends to look like when I travel.
Anyone wants to join me?
I would love it.
But,
but because of this,
I am able to choose how I set myself up when it comes to working,
right?
So that first picture,
whether it's outside of a pool in Bali where I'm overlooking the ocean,
I can,
I can sit there for the afternoon and do my email.
I can book a room that has my own private pool like this place in India,
uh,
where I am able to,
again,
at the end of every day,
I take five minutes to be in nature,
to be by myself in nature or in this other option here.
Um,
it doing yoga first thing every morning when I was in Vietnam.
It's a good way for me to start my day.
And there's hotels out there that are offering all of these options.
Same with healthy food,
right?
There are so many choices these days.
If you know where to look,
it does take a little bit of research.
Um,
but once you find the places that you like,
especially if these are areas that you travel all the time,
these are great resources for you to just have.
Um,
you know,
you found,
I started this,
uh,
conversation telling you that I was in a hotel room in Italy and I had no idea
where I was.
Well,
what's the first thing that I started doing for the next few days after that
trip is I would get up a half an hour earlier and I would completely ignore the
breakfast that was at my hotel with my team and I would go out and I would walk
the streets and I would find a local place to have my Cappuccino in the morning
because that set me up like,
okay,
I'm here,
I'm in Italy.
I feel like I'm participating and it made me happy.
Right?
And that's the key.
You're going to work better and you're going to work smarter when you set
yourself up,
uh,
in ways that work for you and your body.
So we've gone through the whole trip and it's time to come home,
right?
What is it about business travel,
our travel?
How can you create these routines?
How can you live well on the road so that you can work smarter in yield,
better results for you in your personal life and for the business that you're
taking care of.
So it's important that you create these pre-travel routines.
It's important that you work them and stick to them.
They're going to change throughout your,
your time that you're using them.
And that's okay.
Um,
and what you need to do is once you find things that work for you,
you need to condition yourself and unique to condition those around you for your
return.
So what does that mean exactly?
Do you know?
Like,
okay,
I'm going to take a red eye may and maybe your company offers comp time.
So you worked on a weekend,
you're taking a red eye,
you land,
you're landing Monday morning.
Are you expected to be in the office right away?
If not,
see if you can give yourself a date of recover,
uh,
or if you are expected to be in the office,
maybe you can plan your week out and you push all your meetings till Wednesday.
So you give yourself time to recover.
You give yourself a little break and it sets others up for how they interact
with you.
What I love to do and I've learned throughout the years is my out of office
notification.
So what I do is I place my out of office notification to go live a day before I
leave and not to end until a day after I come home.
And what's nice about that is again,
it's setting up others that I'm might not be available.
Of course I have the option to turn it off early or go back to work early.
But what this does is it creates boundaries and it creates expectations for
those around you and,
and sort of trains them on what you found to work for you when it comes to
business travel.
So thank you guys.
It was a pleasure to be here and I hope you learned a little something that you
can take with you on your next trip.
Um,
I'm thrilled that you're going to get a copy of the book and I hope that you can
find more tips and tricks in there that will help you travel.
Um,
and I mentioned to you,
I do run PROBASCO,
which is a wellness travel company,
and I'm thrilled to say that we are actually part of the Google perks program.
So if there is ever an opportunity that you guys want to take a vacation,
um,
whether a group setting or a private setting,
uh,
because we're part of the Google PR perks program,
there's some added discounts in there as well.
So hopefully I can see you guys on the road.
Um,
we do have a little setup for Q and.
A.
If anyone has any questions that they want to ask,
I'm happy to answer them.
If not,
that's okay.
Any questions?
No.
Okay,
cool.
All right.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
It was lovely to be here.